speaking of watching anime i know a
bunch of people who have also been
watching anime
very publicly uh it's probably very old
news by the time this episode gets the
dumbest [ __ ] of 2022 so far but
but so has just begun we're already
taking an l but yeah basically at the
time of recording uh pokemane has been
banned for watching avatar the last
airbender and also disguise toast has
also been banned for watching death
notes i believe um on their twitch
streams uh to their tens of thousands of
viewers and i uh by the time this gets
released maybe more people will be
banned maybe not i don't know but it's
definitely
sparked a discussion about
copyright and dmca and i think people
online are calling it the tv matter
which uh i couldn't [ __ ] believe was
a real thing polygon wrote this article
that was like oh this guy starts he was
just testing out the tv meta and i think
my favorite comment i saw a lot of quote
retweet was like calling it the tv meta
is like shooting yourself in the head
and calling it the gun better
limewire wasn't piracy it was just
engaging in the music
the tv met a strat is priority
pirate doesn't do that
so dark it's so dumb it's the dumbest
argument it's crazy like watching stuff
like the uh totally not mark right with
like toei yeah just like nuking his
channel yeah for like talking about one
piece yeah for not even breaking dmca
you know and then
you know the twitch stream is just go
and watch the entirety of hunter hunter
yeah because i remember like when i
first heard about this i thought it was
i thought it was actually just like a
joke yeah i thought i thought it's like
a parody article i'm just like where's
the onion article and then i then i log
on to and then i log on to twitch
and then i see one of like the biggest
streamers on the pla i'm just gonna [ __ ]
i saw xqc yeah streaming hunter hunter
like innocent like a hundred thousand
people and i'm just like i was watching
because i was like is that is there a
meme like where's the meme coming and i
slowly realized oh they weren't joking
people are actually doing this and then
um conor informed me that ludwig had
already made a video about it and i
think what bothered me was that people
were like calling
like calling him out for calling other
people out for being like yeah yeah why
are you why are you knocking on people
or something like that and i'm just like
imagine you're like broadcasting a
football match in a football stadium
that you don't own because that's what
the equivalent of it is right they're
broadcasting this to like 90 000 people
one guy's like uh is that is that
allowed and like and people are just
actually like shh don't tell people and
it's just like are you [ __ ] kidding
me there's 90 000 people watching this
right now
how can you snitch on someone when
there's 90 000 people watching this one
[ __ ] thing
so dumb and the fact that people try to
argue it's fair use or anything it's
just so stupid
yeah the fear is ridiculous i understand
right because a lot of the viewers who
are watching this probably enjoyed it
they probably loved watching xqc watch
hunter hunter yeah of course i'm sure
everyone would love to watch us watch
jojo unfortunately we can't do that
because one
we're not [ __ ] dumb we don't just
watch [ __ ] when literally we literally
be breaking the law i i did a watch
along of jojo on my stream
uh but i didn't show the visuals i
didn't show audio i have time step
you can go to your netflix and we can
watch along yeah it's not as good of
course it sucks because you can't see it
yeah but it's against the law to do that
yeah and also we live in japan we'd
probably actually be thrown in jail if
we did that yeah oh yeah no you will
um you know it's just like what what
annoyed me the most about it was again
like it was people
trying to be like it was very like
tribal essence they were like you can't
say my stream is bad for doing it they
were just watching you know it doesn't
do any harm so what if they get banned
it's like yeah but yeah because that
streamer already makes like five million
dollars a year of course they don't give
a [ __ ] if they get banned yeah but like
what about the guy you know there's
other smaller streamers who maybe enjoy
the the freedoms of the current
copyright system where they can kind of
you know tell the line a little bit
safer you know not not watching stuff
but maybe i can show you a clip yeah
remember you couldn't watch youtube on
twitch before yeah you know you can now
and even then that's controversial but
i just feel like it's selfish of like
the bigger creators who already are well
established don't have to worry about
income or anything and they can get away
with it
yeah right and they'll come back you
know they'll get banned they'll come
back they don't give a [ __ ] that you
know i
you know if anything them getting banned
is just more publicity to them yeah
because that's why right it's like it's
like you can get banned and you're a
headline and people are like oh my god
you're banned huh that's so crazy we'll
come back and like you'll get even more
viewers and you come back it's like it's
just i don't know it just seems selfish
to me it is and the the fact that
everyone's trying to call it a meta and
play a joke with it and stuff is really
frustrating when you know you know we we
work in japan right we talk a lot with
the you know with the anime companies
and try and work with them and try to
convince them that youtubers and stuff
aren't psychopaths i think that's what
like
bothered me the most yeah which is like
as someone who does make content that
really does require fair use and a
strong argument for fair use even i
think like sometimes i'm still like
touting the line sometimes with how
companies view my content right because
it's such a new concept that it's going
to take time to like convince big
companies that hey please don't strike
my stuff because it is under fair use
and
when you have when you have like [ __ ]
like this and then on the other end of
the spectrum you have people just
broadcasting licensed tv shows movies
anime whatever it's just what is what's
going to happen is that it's just going
to make it harder for the [ __ ] 60 70
year old guy looking at new content to
be like well i guess everyone's just
broadcasting my [ __ ] right well i guess
i should strike down everyone what is
the thing that's going to happen is that
it's going to make it hard for big
corporations to tell the difference
between what is fair use and what isn't
because when there's people who are
abusing the system because this is an
abuse of the system then it's just going
to be harder for the guy who was
actually trying to stay within the
system to prove that he is actually
staying within the system yeah i feel
there's just so many like youtubers on
twitch streams just content creators who
are like you know doing our best to like
at least try and like yeah as you were
saying like show the japanese
corporations being like hey you know
fair use is a thing yeah we're not using
your stuff all the time for malicious
intent we do it because we genuinely
love it we want people to know about it
yeah and but we will follow the rules
that are laid out as much as we can but
at the same time you know i scratch your
back you scratch mine you know like kind
of like
forgive me sometimes you know yeah but
now with this whole [ __ ] tv meta
[ __ ] if i feel all that effort has
just gone back to zero yeah especially
if if it's speculating of course but
like obviously like it you know it could
it could really take a lot of time yeah
i mean like i mean the music industry
did it with twitch eventually they were
like oh [ __ ] uh yeah you shouldn't be
sure streaming music it's not good and
people are like whatever i'm testing out
the music matter you know yeah it
because like the thing though the thing
the other thing that bothered me is that
you know you can't really feign
ignorance because there is a precedence
for this
youtubers have felt it for [ __ ] years
with their copyright system even twitch
streamers and i know a lot of twitch
streamers i complained a lot when they
had their dmca
controversy with the music thing that
happened right where basically every
piece of music just got claimed and you
couldn't even play some games because
some of the music was bound to happen
anyway yeah youtube have been dealing
with that for years yeah like it's you
know i i don't know it's very entitled
you know and that's what it is it is
entitlement a lot of the the streamers
that were doing this yeah just like
don't give a [ __ ] because
why would they they don't mind yeah they
get the headlines they get the views
they already got paid they already have
these contracts with these companies and
then and they know they'll come back
yeah yeah because they get special
treatment yeah and then you have like
people on the other side of the fence
people like totally not mark who like if
you don't know the story behind what
happened with tony not mark i believe
like toei strikes hundreds of his videos
over 150 over like 150 videos at once uh
some of them not even even like having
any copyrighted material on there right
some of them were just like i believe
his face or like
some of them some of them were drawings
of dragon ball characters that he yeah
yeah and so his channel basically got
completely like so many of these videos
got completely wiped away and he was
like fighting tooth and nail yeah to
like try to get in contact with toei to
be like please toei bring my videos out
of copyright jail please this is fair
use and i believe that even now it's not
been sorted no i believe now is he he
basically just like gave up yeah i
believe he just was just so [ __ ]
heartbreaking because i think like a
third of his channel just disappeared
yeah exactly and that's like it's like
could you imagine that it's just like
years of works gone yeah and that to me
it's just like well it's like there's
this guy fighting tooth and nail to try
and prove that his videos are [ __ ]
fair use and his videos do deserve to be
able to use yeah
to look to like a company that doesn't
know the difference between fair use not
and then on the other side of the
spectrum you have other people who are
abusing the system to be like well you
know whatever the ban the the ban
hammers coming down i don't care i can i
can take like a
two-day vacation a month vacation
whatever um and the people who feel the
repercussions are the people who
are like on the load end of the tier
list with
let me rephrase that oh enter the
spectrum lower end of the spectrum yeah
of twitch streamers yeah yeah the
the smaller content creators that's
that's the [ __ ] word i was looking
for the smaller concerts
you know a lot of these the bigger
content creators you know i know or you
know i think highly often it was just
kind of sad seeing them do this and like
yeah some of them just not caring and i
was just like this is just sad like you
know
i also just think you should be a good
example yeah like why not just like make
stuff i don't know like because what's
gonna happen is the big streamers do it
then everyone goes oh if the big
streamer is doing it i can do it too
yeah but of course they don't realize
those big streamers if they get in
trouble all they'll get is a slap on the
wrist if the smaller creator does it
they're probably [ __ ] permabanned
yeah because i'm just like
like to preface this i don't this isn't
like us trying to start drama with any
of the content creators that did this
because a lot of the content creators i
actually respect as content creators
yeah um it was like kind of said i was
just a bit disappointed that they did
yeah yeah they didn't set a better
example uh because they i like i know
that
you know we're all content creators we
know what's going on here you know yeah
we know what the repercussions are going
to be or that what they could be so it's
just
like i couldn't understand why they were
poking the hornet's nest i guess
some of them were doing it you know
intentionally trying to get banned as
well right some of them admitted that
that they wanted to be banned right
because it's good for headlines as well
yeah yeah you know if you're if you're a
bigger name and you have more websites
you know because there are websites that
are just dedicated to you know
literally just talking about twitch
streamers yeah and then like post these
articles they get them recommended all
the time on google oh yeah of course you
won't believe what ludwig said it'll be
like lotus i i like jump king
i hate those articles they're so [ __ ]
welcome to journalism
[Laughter]
it's a little thing called independent
journalism but it's like how have you
then you know at least take a click bait
and not even made it somewhat
interesting and actually even more
boring yeah
no because like i i think what the other
thing that made me like lose brain cells
when i was like scrolling on my twitter
to see what the reaction was was the
amount of people who were calling out
people who were like
basically saying hey you maybe you
shouldn't you know stream
uh or broadcast anime movies to like
your audience whatever and anyone who
said that
was basically
basically called out to being like for
being like a corporate bootlicker or
something like that you know or just
like why are you defending the
corporations and it's just like this it
turned the argument into something
completely different because we all know
dmca is like a decade old [ __ ] law
that is outdated for how the internet
works right yeah um we're like we're
content creators we we know that there
are so many things that are broken about
the dmca system we know that but that's
a separate issue to what is going on
here you know a system can be broken and
people can also abuse the system at the
same time they
they don't have to be mutually uh they
don't have to be the same thing they can
be mutually exclusive
um and just just seeing people try to
defend this just like kind of kind of
just made me [ __ ] lose it was weird
it was really weird seeing how open
everyone was like yeah no of course it's
okay and i'm like yeah
just because you like it doesn't mean
it's okay and just because you can't be
bothered to go into google and look it
up yourself it's like like obviously it
would be sick to watch anime with ninety
thousand people live oh it would be safe
i would love to do that yeah we can't
we're not
allowed until until again these like ip
holders understand that it's okay and
we're not saying this shouldn't be the
case you know what i would say that if a
company wants to be [ __ ] five heads
they would allow people they would they
would allow people to stream all their
old [ __ ] forgotten shows and bring it
to a new audience i think that would be
a five-head move but until they come
until people allow it it's still illegal
you know
you still you're still like you're still
putting risk that you're putting you're
still putting risk on an entire platform
that you're going to put the clamp down
for all the content creators on that
platform you know it's like that
japanese youtuber who got to react to
all of attack on titan and like oh yeah
right he like uploaded all of him yeah
he had he had this uh he had this deal
with the attack on titan ip
and he was just like oh yeah so uh you
got a second channel and it's got like a
million subs uh just put all of attack
on titan on it you're alive yeah with
him reacting yeah i saw that with him
reacting to it and it was completely
legal you know what's crazy to me is
that like
the whole entire youtube community
everyone everyone online hated reaction
channels yeah they came down so goddamn
hard in them and like 2015-16 yeah and
then like why is it different now i
don't understand no everyone what
happened like is it because it's live is
that the only difference like i don't
understand the twitch meta the tv the
react meta the three members the reactor
i guess
i guess what we've learned what we've
learned
what we've learned is that
it's it's it's bad it's a bad thing to
do
unless your favorite content creator is
doing it then it's not yeah exactly
all right that's a good message to end
it
yeah
i just want to go throughout like all of
history and just just start calling like
the most despicable acts of human
history just like a meta